[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour un nouveau numéro du
7-8 europe le magazine européen de la
rédaction de tv 60,18 pose ses caméras
ce mois ci dans le val d'oise à cergy
précisément nous allons vous faire
découvrir le fab lab local littéralement
en français
un laboratoire de fabrication il va
fêter bientôt ses deux ans et se trouve
en plein coeur du campus de l'université
de cergy pontoise ce nouvel espace est
dédié à l'innovation et la recherche a
profité des fonds européens pour sa
construction c'est un véritable espace
de partage pour les entrepreneurs les
étudiants mais aussi les simples
citoyens
ici ils peuvent venir développer leur
projet et trouver une aide précieuse et
variées elles les espaces de ce genre se
multiplient un peu partout en ile de
france
nous irons ensuite au parlement européen
de strasbourg pour l'interview politique
notre invité est jean-luc schaffhauser
élu sur la liste de l'ex front national
en 2014
nous évoquerons les prochaines élections
européennes avec lui jean luc chef à
other nous dira notamment qui lui est
favorable à une europe des nations
et puis enfin dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission vous retrouverez vos
rendez vous habituel l'histoire de
l'europe avec la signature en février
2001 du traité de nice
ce traité n'est pas forcément le plus
connu mais il était à très important
notamment en vue de l'élargissement de
l'union européenne à l'est
et puis notre comparaison européenne
consacré ce mois ci aux minima sociaux
[Musique]
c'est donc ici en plein coeur du campus
de l'université de cergy pontoise qui
est installé le la boîte un lieu unique
sur ce campus sis au mètre carré en tout
mise à disposition évidemment du public
universitaire mais aussi économique ou
encore des simples bricoleur aux curieux
on y trouve des espaces de travail de
nombreux outils et un cadre idéal pour
favoriser à l'émergence des projets
locaux
les fonds européens ont financé à 40%
des presque 700 mille euros nécessaires
à sa construction
nous allons rencontrer l'un des
responsables de ce lieu de vie atypique
bastien vernier il sera notre guide pour
les prochaines minutes
[Musique]
bonjour bastien je te les alors on est
ici dans un endroit on va dire atypique
et qui résume bien selon vous le ce
qu'est le la boîte
est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous
expliquer pourquoi ici et qui est
qu'elle est justement l'état d'esprit du
la boîte alors la boîte c'est avant tout
un lieu d'innovation sociale
on parle beaucoup des fab lab avec
l'innovation technologique des outils
des machines d'impression 3d mais sans
personne
il n'y a pas d'innovation du coup de la
base de la boîte déjà assez d espace
pour que les gens puissent se rencontrer
puis ce travail puisse étudier puissent
échanger des compétences aux autres
ensuite ça peut être des machines des
outils alors des outils numériques
imprimantes imprimante 3d haute mais
aussi des outils traditionnels ça peut
être des marteaux des tournevis des six
est vraiment accompagner toutes les
étapes de la réalisation concrétisation
d'un projet enfin c'est une communauté
et ça c'est vraiment le point
névralgique dans l'anneau fab lab ou de
la boîte
c'est une communauté avec des gens qui
ont des projets des idées et des
compétences et qui vont échanger qui
vont faire fabriquer et peut-être
collaborer avec des personnes et nous
notre rôle c'est vraiment ça c'est de
mettre en relation ces personnes mais
peint aussi des rencontres mairie annexe
à faire mal chez des gens avec des
choses qui peuvent être complémentaires
dans la communauté évidemment et le but
aussi et ce qui est important de
souligner c'est que ici c'est vraiment
ouvert un tout le monde ces
entrepreneurs ça peut être étudiant et
de simples curieux qui n'ont pas
forcément de le projet bien avancé
c'est peut-être entrepreneurs des
étudiants des jeunes des moins jeunes
les artistes des créateurs d
des associations on travaille beaucoup
aussi avec des associations locales de
développer les projets avec eux avec des
structures entrepreneuriale aussi du
territoire qui a company qui finance des
entrepreneurs locaux des étudiants aussi
des différents établissements
d'enseignement supérieur du quartier qui
est un des entrées aussi du lieu sachant
qu'on a dans un moins de deux kilomètres
autour de sion n'a fait même 80 90 % des
étudiants du territoire en commerce en
art en droit sciences humaines
ordinateur est vraiment de quoi faire
vous est ouvert depuis avril 2010 est
alors selon les premiers chiffres 7000 à
7500 personnes viennent ici sur sur un
an
est ce que vous diriez que vous avez
trouvé votre place dans ce campus au
sein de l'université de cergy pontoise
est ce que vous avez trouvé votre public
votre voix à vous il ya deux dynamiques
il ya trouvé sa place donc là du coup on
arrive aussi sur une nouvelle page aussi
sur un quartier qui a 50 ans selon elle
une nouvelle et cette année on fête les
50 ans de la vie de nouvelles un
quartier qui se cherche à se renouveler
et du coup leur honneur de ce quartier
au delà des grands projets urbains ya le
projet de campus international car comme
se développer sur ce quartier depuis un
deux trois ans hélas la boîte c'est une
des premières paires de ce projet le
public il est identifié le discours
identifié maintenant et on est sur une
nouvelle d'étape maintenant à nous de
lancer cette dynamique et c'est ce qu'on
se fixe pour 2019 que d'une offre une
certaine manière est ce qu'on comprend
du coup c'est le plus important ici
c'est la communauté je vous propose
justement on va aller voir un
entrepreneur quelqu'un qui est un projet
qui développe ici pour la boîte
[Musique]
bonjour david pour nicolas alors vous
vous êtes porteur de projet vous êtes en
pleine reconversion professionnelle vous
êtes au la boîte vous profiter des
installations ici depuis quelques mois
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
justement quel est votre reconversion
professionnelle ce que vous faites ici
concrètement alors je suis actuellement
en prototypage donc je crée des produits
en fait que je compte commercialiser par
la suite donc ce sont des modèles numéro
un on va dire et donc par la suite je
compte les mettre en valeur ses des
réseaux sociaux donc par photos vidéos
et le but c'est de faire de bons
sondages dans le cadre du 18 du marché
dessus
ok ce sont des produits un peu on va
dire atypique puisque ils serviront à
l'univers des jeux de société c'est ça
exactement et je m'adresse uniquement
enfin uniquement
je voudrais surtout aux joueurs après la
vocation de la société sera surtout de
faire du mobilier en bois pour les jeux
de société ce sera quoi pour du
rangement par exemple du rangement de
l'utilisation comme tables de jeu en
général du la mise en valeur son
détriment par exemple
alors expliquez nous pourquoi vous êtes
venus ici au la boîte comment comment ça
s'est passé et surtout qu'est ce que
vous trouvez ici qui est intéressant
pour vous l'avantagé de pouvoir avoir un
parc machines à bois tout autour à
disposition et pourra travailler sans
avoir forcément investir dans des
machines parce que pour pour créer une
société donc il faut des machines mais
sans machine on nota prototype et voilà
ça veut dire que sans la boîte
concrètement pour vous ça ça prendrait
plus de temps de faire votre projet même
voir ça serait impossible peut-être
alors peut-être pas impossible mais en
tout cas le fait d'être ici me facilite
beaucoup
l'opération et je gagne beaucoup de
temps sur mon projet au delà de ça
j'aime le côté humain échanges
ici c'est vraiment chouette de pouvoir
partager des expériences avec d'autres
personnes qui portent des projets
notamment une personne qu'il va ainsi
qu' qui vient pour créer ce qu'il vienne
virtuel donc et puis du coup on s'est
mis en lien on a peut-être des projets
en commun et c'est la richesse de la
boîte se permettre de pouvoir mettre des
personnes en lien ici mieux que de
travailler tout seul jacques soit dans
un gars ça c'est ça merci beaucoup david
et puis du coup bon courage dans la
suite de votre projet merci pour plus
d'information pour ceux qui sont curieux
et qui voudraient éventuellement avoir
des informations il ya évidemment le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
vos écrans la boîte point fr et pour
ceux qui n'habitent pas non plus dans le
point dans le val d'oise à cergy il y a
à peu près 80 dizaines de la boîte de
fab lab en ile de france vous pouvez en
profiter et évidemment on poursuit à
présent notre émission à strasbourg au
parlement européen en compagnie de
l'eurodéputé jean-luc schaffhauser élu
sur la liste du rassemblement national
il y a cinq ans le parti de marine le
pen est aujourd'hui en tête des sondages
à quelques semaines des élections
européennes
c'est l'interview politique de ce mois
[Musique]
et nous sommes donc désormais au
parlement européen à strasbourg avec
l'eurodéputée d'ile-de-france jean-luc
schaffhauser bonsoir bonsoir vous avez
été élus en 2014 sur la liste soutenue
par l'ex front national on parle
désormais de rassemblement national
le parti a dévoilé récemment les
premiers noms de ses candidats pour les
élections européennes 12 non vous n'êtes
pas dans cette liste pourquoi est ce que
c'est vous qui avait décidé de ne pas
être candidat à la candidature certains
disent que je n'ai pas voulu être
candidat je n'ai pas non plus refuser
d'être candidat vous êtes donc que très
intéressement débordant écoutez j'ai
souhaité répliquer aux 64 ans si chaud
nouveau mandat ça me ramène à 69 ans
j'ai déjà pas fait le tour du monde en
bateau que j'avais prévu par cause parce
que j'ai été en député bonbons mon nom
je suis prêt mois à à refaire un tour
mais pas n'importe quelle condition donc
les discussions continuent j'attends
qu'on vienne
il faut il faut vous séduire c'est ça en
gros c'est une question de séduction je
suis très content que mon ami hervé
juvin
soit dans et puis aussi mariani oui les
élèves ex-ministre voilà et thierry est
un ami aussi et donc que voulez-vous que
je vous dise
un article du parisien récemment parle
de tension de désaccord politique avec
le parti et vous cite je suis en très
bons termes avec tout le monde mais ne
le sont pas forcément avec moi puisque
je pense que l'invention et il est faux
et fort hills est pas faux ce qui a été
dit je pense qu'il faut continuer dans
le rassemblement et le rassemblement ce
n'est pas simplement des personnes qu'on
pique de ci de là c'est également la
négociation avec des forces politiques
sur la base d'un programme politique
mais je pense qu'il faut laisser deux
éléments le programme
c'est pour ça que je sors un livre sur
la question européenne et d'autre part
il faut effectivement rassembler aussi
des forces politiques pas seulement des
individualités groupe politique le
excusez moi c'est le hélène c'est ça
l'europe des nations des libérateurs qui
est une parfaite réussite
suffisant de partir sur cette base la
puissance je vous parle du rassemblement
à l'intérieur de l'anc du pays de la
france pour pouvoir par exemple négocier
avec je pense de la fosse je pense qu'il
faut effectivement cinéphile je crois
cela a été fait mais je pense qu'il faut
nous retrouver sur la place sur la base
d'une plateforme politique élargir
jusqu'à jusqu aux républicains
aujourd'hui c'est le programme qui
rassemble c'est pas les individus moi
j'étais aussi de ceux qui on est
privilégiés qui ont été privilégiés par
rapport aux anciens puisque
j'ai été élu comme personne qui n'était
pas du rassemblement national ou des
front national à l'époque donc je
reconnais et c'est tout à fait normal
que d'autres privilégient que d'autres
sont dans la même situation plutôt
privilégié mais mai et que marine
privilégie cette méthode mais je pense
qu'il faut aller au delà
on ne connaît pas d'ailleurs pour
l'instant le programme du front national
pour ces élections européennes
on a toujours les mêmes rengaines qui
reviennent mais moi je viens avec un
proposition je dis pas que c'est la
proposition unique mais il faut une base
sur laquelle on se retrouve on discute
et on se rassemble vous connaissez
jordan bardella 23 ans tête de liste du
rassemblement national sur la seule est
connue quand je suis allé dans le 93
lors des élections européennes
absolument il vient de là bas des gens
lors des élections européennes que j'en
garde un bon souvenir
vous pensez quoi et qu'il est va
croissance un peu la tête mais c'est
très sympathique tout ça gg la fille de
ma fille qui a le même âge voilà ce qui
prouve aussi vous peut-être que moi je
devrais ce que je devrais aller à la
retraite si je ne voyais et c'est un peu
un peu un peu critique non là dessus se
sont levés à écouter à 23 ans j'étais
jeune fonctionnaire à 25 ans j'étais
chef du service de l'énergie s'est déjà
attaché parlementaire avec trois ans
j'étais avec bernard stasi au cabinet de
bernard stasi
donc je ne serais ce que je n'ai pas d'à
priori contre la jeunesse j'en ai
profité aussi elle passe on a parlé de
thierry mariani ancien
ministre des transports sous nicolas
sarkozy donc ancien membre de l'ump il
ya aussi un ex député girondin de l'ump
qui a rejoint le rassemblement national
pour ces élections européennes
est ce que vous diriez que c'est là la
vie politique française qui continuent
de bouger de se reconstruire ou alors
finalement ce sont des salles politique
et il ne faut pas faire ce que sarkozy a
fait c'est à dire c'est à dire
rassembler des personnes l'opération
besson par exemple à l'époque qui avait
ouvert à la gauche
voilà il faut pas faire dit il faut se
retrouver il faut prendre plutôt la
méthode mitterrand c'est à dire la
méthode plateforme programme commun
rassemblement des forces politiques qui
étaient là la méthode de de gaulle si je
voulais dire la méthode de l'union
nationale
ce que je voulais dire c'est que thierry
mariani notamment c'est un peu un second
couteau aujourd'hui on va pas se mentir
oui mais enfin il rappelé il son
jugement de valeur et il nous présente
bien ce courant certains diraient
populiste au sein de ce qui était
autrefois le plus mp un peu comme le
renverser le sens et c'est pourquoi je
me sens très proche de lui
voilà un peu comme laurent wauquiez mais
peut-être avec moi moins de mal être
finalement le rassemblement national
c'est l'ump
dia si je vous comprends bien si vous
regardez le programme qui avait
autrefois jacques chirac et le rpr et le
rpr et des gaullistes aux européennes il
y avait beaucoup d'éléments alors là y
compris sur l'immigration nous nous
serions presque modéré parlons parlons
du fond désormais est-ce que vous pensez
que les parties alors je ne sais pas
comment les nommer nationaliste
eurocritique eurosceptiques bref vous
m'avez compris je suis sûr que ce soit
le rassemblement national de fp aux
autrichiens la ligue du nord en italie
le paysan en pologne
est ce qu'ils sont capables ces parties
là d'être majorité en mois de mai
prochain
je pense qu'ils peuvent être
éventuellement constituer une minorité
gêné de blocage majoritaire je ne pense
pas encore mais ça ne changera rien aux
institutions européennes c'est ce que
j'allais vous dire je pense qu'il faut
sortir des institutions européennes
alors politiquement je pense c'est pas
très adroit de le dire comme ça parce
que tout le monde à s'effrayer où il à
sortir de leur rang même si je débarque
en force au parlement européen ça ne
changera rien concrètement pour l'heure
vous savez pour changer les traités faut
l'unanimité des pays
vous aurez toujours un pays qui se
refusera à changer les traités
c'est un début de mouvement important et
je pense effectivement que c'est un
début de mouvement
ça oblige effectivement à définir une
plateforme et un projet commun européen
qu'est ce que c'est l'europe des nations
alors moi je suis convaincu que l'europe
des nations
c'est la seule manière de construire
j'ai toujours été un c'est pas changé
1988 j'ai créé une malle une âme pour
l'europe avec un mes amis qui est qui
était le président de la cftc du
syndicat chrétien où je montre que c'est
sur la base des états et des nations
qu'on peut seulement bâtir l'europe
s'il devait y avoir une idée à mettre en
avant peut-être pour convaincre les gens
concrètement une idée qui pourrait
modifier selon vos idées d'etats-nations
votre idée est la nation qui peut
modifier leur vie ça ce cas là qu'elle
serait dans quels domaines seule
l'europe des états et des nations est
une europe coopérative seul cette
structure permet la création sinon vous
êtes dans la concurrence et la
concurrence finit toujours en guerre
économique et in fine est en guerre tout
court
donc seule l'europe des états et des
nations permet de construire l'europe de
la coopération
jean-luc schaffhauser on va faire une
pause dans cet entretien pour évoquer
l'histoire avec une date qui a marqué le
vieux continent aujourd'hui on se penche
sur la signature du traité de nice en
février 2001 si ce traité n'est pas le
plus connu de tous il a permis d'adapter
les institutions européennes à
l'élargissement en 2004 les précisions
de philippe le guen coordinateur adjoint
pour la maison jean monnet basée à
bazoches sur guyonne dans les yvelines
alors nous sommes dans le
contexte
où l'on sait que un certain nombre de
nouveaux pays à cette époque se prépare
à l'adhésion et on sait qu'ils vont
adhérer et finalement les adhérons pour
certains en 2000 2004 pour d'autres un
peu plus tard mais il fallait organiser
les institutions parce que les
institutions et nos parrains en
particulier le système de prise de
décision le système de pondération des
voix dans le cas de la majorité
qualifiée était et est évidemment prévu
pour 15 pays et on allait se retrouver à
donc effectivement ce traité de nice est
une tentative alors certains l'ont
critiqué en disant que c'était pas
complètement abouti mais enfin c était
au moins
décidé comme cela afin de préparer
l'élargissement de dix pays qui sont
arrivés à tous ensemble et il fallait
mieux se préparer à temps alors ça a été
en effet plusieurs années quand même de
préparation ça a permis de revoir le
système du poids démographique des
pondérations 2d vote à la majorité
qualifiée
ça a permis aussi de revoir le rôle des
institutions le nombre de commissaires
notamment puisque bon il a fallu s'y
tenir compte de cela donc la position
qui a été décidé à l'époque ces deux
d'avoir autant de commissaires que
européen dans la commission européenne
que d'états membres
et puis on pensait avec ce traité de
nice que est bien très vite un autre
traité à les compléter cela et revoir de
manière encore plus approfondie plus
définitive le fonctionnement des
institutionnels
alors on connaît tous les chèques
ensuite du traité dit constitutionnel de
2005 puisque non
ratifiée par la france suite au
référendum et par les pays bas donc
finalement le traité de nice est resté
en vigueur
bon an mal an jusqu'à l'adoption du
traité de lisbonne en 2009
donc finalement ce traité de nice qui
qu'on voulait peut-être provisoire est
bien à est quand même resté sur une
grande durée et bien il a permis un même
avec des imperfections
quand même au système de prise de
décision européen de continuer à
fonctionner avec 25 et ensuite 27 pays
on vient de le voir avec ce traité de
nice que les institutions européennes
s'étaient transformés en vue de
l'élargissement à l'est en 2004 avec le
recul 15 ans plus tard et avec les
critiques fortement émises par certains
de ces pays à propos justement de la
construction européenne d'aujourd'hui
mais aussi à linverse des remontrances
faites sur les atteintes aux droits en
pologne en roumanie en hongrie
est ce que vous diriez que s'est élargie
cement a été une erreur il a été trop
rapide ou encore qu'on n'aurait pas dû
le faire
tout court j'ai plaidé avant la chute du
mur j'ai rassemblé toute l'opposition
des pays de l'est pour la première fois
ici j'ai rassemblé tous les
révolutionnaires de 1989
ici même dans ce parlement en 1990 et en
1991 j'ai été pour cette ouverture au
pays pour la hongrie la tchécoslovaquie
et la pologne
parce qu'à l'époque c'était la clé co
slovaquie donc je vais pas me contredire
j'ai été le premier il fallait aller
plutôt il est certain que cette europe
élargie ne peut se construire que sur la
base de l'europe des états de l'europe
des nations j'y reviens aujourd'hui il
ya des discussions alors avec la turquie
ça fait très longtemps qu'elles sont au
point mort mais avec eux aussi des pays
des balkans le monténégro la serbie en
d'une intégration d'alice la régie je
connais votre réponse je m'étais plus de
l'ouverture historique à l'europe
historique
moi je suis pas du tout opposé pourtant
géographiquement ça peut se je suis pas
du tout opposé à une telle ouverture à
la condition qu alors on pense europe
continentale avec la russie parce que si
cette ouverture consiste à mettre ces
pays dans le camp occidental en
opposition avec la russie au lieu de
faire l'europe unis et l'europe
puissance ont détruit l'europe et on la
met dans un camp et on ne construit pas
le monde multipolaire
tout dépend de la manière dont on voit
les choses justement j'allais vous poser
cette dernière question sur sur la rue
si on vous dit pro russe est ce qu'on
peut lire je ne vous connais pas
personnellement vous êtes vous pour une
remise à plat des relations avec la
russie
je ne saurai côté en pro russe je pense
que la russie est un élément fondamental
de la stratégie pour les intérêts de mon
pays pour la france ya intérêt à se
lasser la politique du général de gaulle
c'est la politique même de churchill qui
était également pour un rapprochement du
20e siècle
où allons nous vingt-et-une idées
d'accord mais il est certain que la
puissance continentale que constitue
l'europe avec la russie fait le poids
par rapport à la chine et fait le poids
par rapport aux états unis alors est-ce
que c'est plus intelligent de mettre la
russie dans le camp de la chine et nous
dans le camp des américains je pense pas
je veux une europe indépendante je veux
une europe des nations une europe des
nations fortes et coopératives on l'aura
bien compris on verra si ça va se
concrétiser au mois de mai prochain
pour terminer cette émission on passe à
notre comparaison européenne on cherche
à savoir ce mois-ci quels sont les
niveaux des minima sociaux
en europe vous allez le voir il varie
énormément entre l'ouest et l'est
le point avec olivier jeanne l'ex
responsable du centre europe direct à
saint germain en laye concernant les
dépenses sociales la france est si on pu
lire la championne d'europe en matière
de dépenses sociales on estime qu'elles
dépensent à peu près 30 4% de son pib en
matière de dépenses sociales
elle est suivie
par le danemark qui dépasse qui lui
dépense 30 % de son pib
en matière de dépenses sociales et par
cinq autres pays pays-bas belgique
finlande autriche et italie
si on prend le cas de l'allemagne de nos
voisins allemands eux sont à 29 % de
dépenses sociales on considère qu'il ya
principalement trois types de dépenses
dans les dépenses sociales le premier
poste de dépenses c'est ce qu'on appelle
se sont davantage des dépenses on va
dire qu'ils sont liés à une sorte de
volet sécurité ou en fait qu'ils
comprennent par exemple tout ce qu'ils
sont les dépenses en matière de maladies
de retraite de chômage le deuxième poste
de dépenses dans les dépenses sociales
correspond davantage à un volet
d'assistance ou en fait là on a
davantage tout ce qui est les dépenses
en matière de famille de logement et
d'emploi et enfin on a un dernier volet
qui correspond plus spécifiquement à des
dépenses de on va dire de solidarité
visant en fait à aider les personnes qui
se trouvent en situation d'exclusion
sociale et nous en france et ce qu'on
connaît sous le nom de minima sociaux
les dépenses qui constituent les minima
sociaux de bari aussi en fonction des
états par exemple en france on a
principalement les minima sociaux on a
le rsa on peut avoir les aides pour les
personnes en fin de droit on peut avoir
aussi certaines aides pour
les personnes handicapées on se rend
compte que certains pays ont décidé en
fait de fusionner toutes ces aides et de
verser une seule aide unique
on a par exemple le cas des pays bas des
pays bas ou du danemark en fait il ya
une garantie de ressources minimum qui
va s'appliquer à la qui va s'appliquer à
la personne quelle que soit cette
situation si on reprend le cas du
danemark cette ressource minimes cette
ressource minimale est à hauteur de 1390
euros par mois tandis qu'au tandis
qu'aux pays-bas est la hauteur de 1173
euros par mois alors ça peut paraître
beaucoup par rapport à tout ce qu'on
connaît en france
il faut aussi prendre en compte un
élément c'est que c'est minima sociaux
sont calculés en fonction du niveau de
vie du pays
merci jean luc chaque fois other d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes membre au parlement européen
du groupe europe des nations et des
libertés groupe où siègent notamment les
euro députés affiliés au rassemblement
national c'est la fin de ce set 8 europe
merci aux équipes du parlement pour la
réalisation de cet entretien on se
retrouve le mois prochain pour un
nouveau numéro 10 il avoue retrouver
cette émission en replay sur tv 78
points comme ou l'application tv 78
merci à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]